Every cancer is a case
of clonal evolution.
Evolution is involved in every
single patient who develops cancer.
No.
Cancer evolution is a different kind of
evolution in the sense that it is short
sighted and it's selfish.
The clones originate through mutations
and then they compete for resources and
for space within the patient.
Two of the key genes that are involved,
or p 16 in [inaudible] 53 they control,
so the cell cycle in Dna repair among
other things and damage to DNA repair
increases mutation rate.
The greater the genetic
diversity in a tumor,
the more likely that it
will progress to malignancy.
So cancer evolution is not something
that is passed from a parent to an
offspring with very, very
few exceptions. There are,
there's a tumor in Tasmanian devils and
there's one other that can actually be
transmitted,
but 99.99% of all cancers are not
passed from parents to offspring.
Their entire evolution occurs within
the body and the lifespan of a single
individual human being.
The revolution is short sighted
because they die with their hosts.
Here's selection is operating
on cell clones over.
No more than about 40
to 50 cell generations.
And that's not enough selective events
to produce any precise adaptation,
but it can produce a rough
adaptation to a local environment.
So a metastasis to the liver,
for example,
can have different characteristics
in a metastasis to along,
and you can show that those differences
have something to do with those two
environments.
Okay?
This lovely picture is from Charlie,
none.
Somatic evolution is actually
orthogonal to germline evolution.
So this green tree down
here shows births of,
for example, your birth,
the birth of your children,
the birth of your grandchildren, and
then each individual looks like a tree.
These are all of the somatic cells that
are growing up out of the single cell of
the Zygote.
And a cancer is going to be a branch
or a twig on one of these trees.
It's produced by competition among
clonal lineages generated by somatic
mutation,
okay.
And these lineage to let these lineages
are extremely genetically heterogeneous
and that's been detected
with many methods.
There are changes that range
from nucleotide sequences
and methylation patterns
to chromosome numbers.
Cancer cells are
competing for nutrients and to evade.
The immune system
and the genetic variants that are better
at those functions increase in number
and frequency. So there are two
very important things going on here.
One is that there's a huge amount of
genetic diversity being generated and the
second is that that genetic diversity is
being trimmed and shaped by competition.
So it's a standard micro evolutionary
scenario where genetic variation is the
fuel for a selection process.
The
two genes in which mutations
are particularly important
are p 16 which is all so
called CD K and two a. This is a
cyclin dependent kinase inhibitor.
It produces two splicing variances.
One of them inhibit CDK four kinase,
which is important for cell
cycle progression and the
other stabilizes p 53 by
sequestering a protein that
degrades p 53 p 53 producers,
a transcription factor that regulate
cell cycle and also suppresses tumor
formation.
It can activate DNA repair proteins,
it can arrest the cell cycle when it
recognizes Dna damage and you can initiate
a pop ptosis if DNA damage
is likely to be irreparable.
Interestingly,
people who inherit only one functional
copy of the TPMT TP 53 gene will almost
certainly developed
tumors in early adulthood.
This is a disease known
as Li Fraumeni Syndrome.
More than 50% of human tumors contain
a mutation or deletion and the TP,
53 g
clonal expansions of p 16 and p 53 lesions
have been found in cancers of skin,
long breast, head, neck, bladder,
brain, kidney, prostate, colon,
stomach, and esophagus. In other words,
these two genes are found to have mutated
in a very wide and important range of
cancers,
expansions of these in
clones or signatures.
That natural selection is favoring clones
that have mutations in these genes.
And so here are papers that you can look
up documenting such expansions of p 53
and p 16 in skin, lung, breast,
head, neck, bladder, brain,
kidney, prostate, colon,
and stomach cancer.
An important finding is that the genetic
diversity in a pre malignant tumor
predicts progression to malignancy.
So Barrett's Esophagus is a condition
of inflammation on the esophagus that
predisposes for a cancer called
Esophageal Adenocarcinoma.
Carlo Maley and his collaborators used
measures for species diversity from
ecology and evolution to measure how
genetically diverse these clones in
Barrett's esophagus war. They
used numbers, different clones,
the Shannon index of diversity
and genetic divergence,
how genetically different
than mutants were.
And all three of these measures predicted
the patients that were more likely to
develop cancer.
So here is the incidents of
Esophageal Adenocarcinoma.
So that's the cancer resulting from
Barrett's Esophagus as a function of the
genetic diversity of the,
uh,
inflammations of verus found
in Barrett's esophagus.
This is the number of years
the patients were followed up.
And what you see on the graph is the
message that the patients that were in the
upper core tile for genetic diversity,
embarrass Esophagus,
uh,
we're also those that have the highest
incidents of esophageal Adenocarcinoma.
Those that were in the lower three core
tiles were much less likely to progress
to cancer.
So the genetic diversity of the conal
system instead of evolving cones,
which is providing the
fuel for natural selection,
is also a predictor of how likely those
clones will result in full on cancer.
Let's take a look at what clonal evolution
looks like and how it looks in cancer.
So here is a picture of
clonal evolution in general.
You'll note that clone a though.
Basically what you see is how much of
space is being occupied by a clone.
Here you have cone,
a Columbian.
See clone a is competitively
superior and it is excluding clone,
be in quote and see. And
it's also including excluding
clone AC. They all pop up,
but they disappear because they're
out competed by A. However,
a B is superior to a.
And so when the bee mutation arises
in a cell that already has a,
it spreads and excludes the others.
However,
the best combination is a, B, and c.
And when the c mutation arises in
a clone that already has a and B,
it spreads notice.
Then the clone a has interfered with clone
ac and it's slowed down the spread of
the scene.
Mutan because the sea is not
effective until B has come along.
If we now look in
Barrett's esophagus here,
the orange background is uh,
in indicating a region of tissue where
there is the inflammation of Barrett's
esophagus. The Gray mutants are
neutral. They pop up and disappear.
Then a p 16 Mutan arises and it spreads
and takes over a neutral Mutan pops ups
in a disappears.
Then there is a p 53 deletion.
However,
the p 16 Muneton out
competes the p 53 deletion.
The p 16 then gets to munes.
It's now homozygous for deletions of p
16 it spreads and takes over and within
that background,
a p 53 deletion arises.
It is within that stem,
that set of cells that have both the p
16 double deletion and a p 53 deletion
that esophageal adenocarcinoma arises.
You notice the two pictures look
fairly similar. In other words,
clonal evolution is going on and there
is a process of colonial interference
that can be documented in
Barrett's esophagus and you
can also see that you need
a sequence of mutations
to get to full on cancer.
So this view now has become standard.
The idea is that there are normal cells.
Then there are what are
called driver mutations.
So they're viewed as being
causal in the spread of cancer,
but it takes a sequence of them until you
get a most recent common ancestor of a
cell that expands and it's clonal lineage
managers to take over and out of this
expanded clone come some that
conform distant metastasis.
So this is now become a
standard view of cancer. It's,
it's a process of clonal evolution and
requires a series of mutations and at a
certain time point a mutation will
occur which allows metastasis.
So to summarize,
cancer starts when a combination of
germline and somatic mutations produces
cells that slip out of cell cycle control,
increase in numbers,
and acquire the ability to move and
to insert themselves into tissues.
Cancers are genetically heterogeneous
sets of clones that are competing with
each other for resources and space.
This is critical.
This is a critical part of how
we visualize what a cancer is.
It's not a single thing. It's a
genetically heterogeneous set of clones.
Competition among the clones generates
natural selection that favors clones that
can grow faster. They can
disperse in the kin, invade
this evolution is short
sighted and selfish.
The cancer is going to die
with the patient. It is not
transmitted to offspring.